they want to be seen as Defenders Of The
Nation footage released by the Army
shows the Army Chief Asim munir
inspecting positions in Pakistani
administered Kashmir one of the most
militarized zones in the world a region
disputed both by India and Pakistan two
nuclear Powers but it's not the
military's role in defending the borders
that's under the spotlight it's their
influence in
politics especially now as Pakistan gets
ready to hold it general elections I
feel it's uh bound to be a hung
Parliament a cocktail of sorts as oued
prime minister Imran Khan seems to have
run out of establishment's favor when I
say establishment it is a military
establishment that I'm talking about or
the Pakistan Army which is the Lord of
the Ring no prime minister in the
country's 76- year history has finished
a full term in office all the main
political parties have felt the Wrath of
the military current front runner noas
Sharif was outed in a military coup when
he tried to sack military Chief Peres
musher zulfikar buo grandfather of the
current Pakistan People's Party head bav
B zardari was AED in a coup and then
executed and former prime minister Imran
Khan has claimed it is the military that
is behind his removal he's now in jail
on corruption charges you've seen on a
number of occasions in the past that um
in the months and weeks leading up to
the election the party that uh the
military happens to not be comfortable
with uh tends to suffer uh before the
election
and it's Imran Khan's PTI that has
suffered their leader is in prison the
symbol of a cricket batch removed from
the ballot paper and the activists
targeted the first military coup took
place in 1958 and since then Pakistan
has spent several decades under military
rule the military is Big Business to
build roads housing projects and
becoming a general means wealth status
and influence over how the nation is run
when Imran Khan refused to back Ukraine
after Russia's Invasion trying to carve
a path of neutrality for pakist is when
Washington reportedly objected as was
revealed in leaked
documents what do you think of us that
we are your slaves and that we'll do
whatever you ask of
[Applause]
us we are friends of Russia and we're
also Friends of the United States we are
friends of China and Europe we are not
part of any Alliance he was removed in a
vot of no confidence and since then
Pakistan's foreign policy has shifted
aligning itself once again with the US
the outcome of these elections have not
yet been decided but one thing the
results will not change is the size role
and influence of the military
establishment Assad B Al jaaz theor
Pakistan make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer